das superwahljahr 2009 10 endete an
diesem sonntag mit einem paukenschlag
die thüringer haben gewählt ein kleines
bundesland aber umso schwieriger sind
die ist die aufgabe die die thüringer
den parteien hinterlassen haben
wie eine regierungsbildung aussehen
könnte kann am heutigen abend noch
niemand sagen
bodo ramelow der spitzenkandidat der
linken und ministerpräsident des landes
hat einen fulminanten sieg eingefahren
er hat sein ergebnis vom letzten mal
noch einmal verbessert es ist das erste
mal dass die linke in einem deutschen
bundesland stärkste kraft wird
seine koalition mit der spd und den
grünen kann ramelow allerdings nicht
fortsetzen
die spd hat noch einmal stark verloren
die grünen sind genauso schlecht wie
beim letzten mal landen bei gut 5
prozent für die grünen die sich seit
einem guten jahren am höhenflug befinden
ist das eine ungewohnte schlechtes
ergebnis
die afg hat sehr gut abgeschnitten das
ergebnis vom letzten mal fast verdoppelt
dabei ist ihr spitzenkandidat böcke der
führer des flügels einer
rechtsnationalen strömung innerhalb der
afd
die vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
wird mit ihm haben alle parteien eine
zusammenarbeit ausgeschlossen
was bleibt also die cdu könnte rein
rechnerisch mit den mit der linken in
einem rot-schwarzen bündnis regieren
allerdings hat sowohl mike mohring der
spitzenkandidat der cdu als auch ein
bodo ramelow der ministerpräsident der
linken eine zusammenarbeit
ausgeschlossen ist bliebe theoretisch
noch das bündnis er hat zwei g2 das
heißt die beiden roten also linke und
spd zusammen mit den beiden geht es also
grünen und gelben strich fdp
das wiederum hat allerdings der fdp chef
christian lindner am heutigen abend
schon ausgeschlossen
es bleibt also dabei dass alle konnten
alle koalitionen die rechnerisch möglich
wären von den parteien nicht gewollt
sind
vorerst muss dass bodo ramelow nicht
stören nach der thüringischen verfassung
kann er erst einmal weiter regieren mit
allen rechten der haushalt für die
thüringer ist erst einmal beschlossen
lang geht das freilich nicht dass es
irgendwann eine neue regierung geben
muss ist vollkommen klar und wie die
aussieht kann an diesem abend noch
keiner sagen